I'm Mandy Baker from National Geographic
Channel and we are here in Ellenville
New York we're shooting a short film
called before Mars which is essentially
the prequel story to the global event
series coming called Mars on a nasty
graphic channel in November we're
telling the story of two of our main
characters from the show Mars when they
were teenagers and first began to be
inspired to want to someday take a great
journey to the red planet this is really
exciting for us for the channel because
it is such a different way to tell the
story to take these characters that have
been established in the show Mars and
tell their backstory so in this story
the basic ideas they move into a new
home and in that home they find this old
ham radio hello their process of
discoveries and adventures they realize
this ham radio can actually contact the
international space station so yesterday
we filmed the most important scene
probably the entire film which is the
final scene where Hannah goes on this
adventure this quest to get a better
signal so that she can talk to an
astronaut in the National Space Station
and it was real challenging because the
script we have written this big
rainstorm that stops Han on she has to
go into a cave and then her radio breaks
down and she still climbs the top and
then she finally reaches and makes a
connection with his astronaut but of
course we had a perfectly beautiful blue
sky day so we had to figure out how can
we still tell this story so we had some
rain machines we had some big trucks
with lots of water on them to create
this big rainstorm and you know then she
hikes up to the day and it's very
challenging because our crew were hiking
up and down these mountains or moving to
this really remote location but in the
end as she's in the mountaintop and the
storm has cleared well you got this
perfect evening
perfect skies nice little wind coming
through
as we were filming it I was getting
goose bumps as she was talking to the
International Space Station and it was a
really powerful moment and it was
exciting to see how all these different
variables and so many different things
that come together to make us seem like
that happened when it all clicks it's a
it's a pretty magical thing
you